now this morning we have the opportunity
to explore the wonderful world of
ecology and our guide is dr. David
skelly dr. skelly is a professor of
ecology here at Yale and he's interested
in amphibians particularly frogs he's
interested in understanding their
patterns in their distribution and their
abundance and the development of
abnormalities his research will in
covering a help and help predict some of
nature's natural patterns and also why
these deformities occur so this we we
expect a real treat this morning so just
sit back and help me welcome dr. skelly
to the podium well it's a real pleasure
to be here and to talk to a lively and
energetic and youthful audience I'm used
to talking to crusty old people and I
know there's some crusty old people in
the audience but you're accompanied by
your young vital folks and so this is
going to be fun I'm going to talk about
science and the swamps today so I am
really an eight year old who got
interested in frogs and then tricked
society into paying me to continue to
play with frogs into my adulthood and
hope to keep doing that so what I'm
going to do today is give you a talk in
two parts first I want to convince you
that there are good reasons to pay
people to study frogs in particular and
and to tell you a little bit about what
what frogs have been able to tell us
about how the world works and then I
want to use that as a segue into talking
about how a biologist how I puvis
scientist me in this example learns
about the world how do you confront some
big question and then use patterns from
the natural world to help you answer a
question that society thinks may be
important so I'm going to start off by
just asking you to consider a frog
almost everyone in this room regardless
of your age has spent some time outside
in their yard or anywhere looking at
these things and trying to figure out
something something about them they're
there for many people growing up that
this is this is one of the animals that
is big enough to be interesting and slow
enough that we can catch it and look at
it and so this is a picture of a bard
River frog this frog lives in the
tropical rainforests of Queensland it's
as you can see that's a that's an adult
sized hand so this is a pretty pretty
big frog and it has a very restricted
distribution it's only found in one tiny
little part of northern Queensland it
lives in a place where there are
monsoonal rains kind of like today
except it's a lot warmer and so you
could ask many questions about why does
it live there why doesn't it live
somewhere else why does its color
pattern look like that why does it have
those big eyes perched up on top of its
head why are frogs funny-looking why do
they look like that so there's just
endless questions you can ask and and
frogs are actually really easy relative
to lots of other animals to answer those
questions so the first reason that
people study frogs is because they're so
easy to work with and so now what I want
to do is step through about a half dozen
examples of things we've learned from
looking at frogs one of the most famous
examples is developmental biology frogs
are vertebrates they've got a backbone
just like all of you and in certain
aspects lots of aspects of their
developmental biology is really really
similar to how all of you developed when
you were inside your mothers and the
nice thing about frogs is that they
develop most of them outside of their
mothers and so these sorry needs is
there Thanks these these this is a frog
egg we call it an embryo and this embryo
is laid outside of the mother and this
is a very early stage embryo it's just
two cells at that point so when when an
egg is late and it's fertilized it forms
a single cell that cell starts to divide
and divide and divide and it starts to
turn into something that we would
recognize as an animal and eventually it
hatches so these are all frog stages our
frog eggs at different stages in the
late 1800s and early 1900s abbr
developmental biologists well founded
that field and one of the first animals
that they started to work on because it
was really handy was the frog and so
this is a fun looking guy here is
Wilhelm roux and Wilhelm Roux discovered
something that has been extremely
important to the history of biology and
too many things that are going on today
that are important to us like
genetically modified crop plants to
cloning to you name it this this guy was
the first experimental embryologist and
what he discovered was that even at this
stage when an embryo has just divided
once from one cell into two cells these
two cells already have different fates
and the way he did that was by taking
this embryo and sticking a hot needle
into one side and killing that cell and
allowing it to continue to develop and
what he got was up to the stage when it
could no longer develop a perfect half
embryo so by this stage just within
minutes of being laid literally minutes
there's already a left half and a right
half to that embryo and when you get to
this stage every one of these cells is
going to develop into different specific
tissues and by discovering this people
were discovering the basis of what in
the future is going to become tissue
based therapies for all of us as we age
if you're if you end up with liver
disease the hope for the future is that
you'll be able to have cells put into
your body that can create new liver
tissues and these guys working on frogs
back in the 1800's sowed the seeds
literally to that that have developed
into into that field another example
that's closer to my own work as an isa
said i'm an ecologist so I I work on how
a a lot of the work I do is working on
what happens to frog populations why are
they going extinct here why are they
having developmental deformities over
there why why are some doing well and
some doing poorly I've also worked on on
how frogs deal with their predators as a
way of understanding how all
animals deal with their predators and
one of the most astounding discoveries
that has been made in this realm in the
past couple of decades is that animals
are capable of not just going oh I'm
scared of a predator but changing their
body shape and their body color within
days so these two animals here and I'm I
apologize that's a little fuzzy these
two animals are the exact same species
they're they're the gray tree frog great
tree frogs live right around here some
of you have no doubt seen them if you've
ever seen a frog crawl up the side of a
house or up a window around here that's
a great tree frog they've got big pads
on their toes and they can crawl right
up surfaces so this is what they look
like as tadpoles and this is a tadpole
that's never seen a predator it's never
been around a predator and this is a
predator over here that's the larvae of
a dragonfly and this animal is actually
a little bit bigger even than this
tadpole and this thing can eat dozens of
tadpoles in a day and if you put this
animal in the presence of this tadpole
within about a week it turns into this
animal this tale is deeper the tail
muscle is bigger and the coloration
turns red this animal is much harder for
this predator to eat it's it's better at
getting away and the red tail this red
flag back here tricks the the predator
into striking towards the tail which it
can survive versus the body which it
can't so it you often find when you go
out into nature and collect these things
these animals with bright bright red
tails but part of the tail is missing so
that's a great strategy and it's it's
it's something that we see not just in
gray tree frogs but in other species and
it's something that people studying
frogs have taught all kinds of
ecologists this is where this was
discovered in part because these changes
were so obvious and so easy to study the
next development I want to talk about is
cryobiology so some of you who are
adults in the audience will remember a
few years ago I'm a Red Sox fan and so
when Ted Williams died it was very sad
and then it was even sadder when there
was all this business about his children
fighting over
whether his body was going to be frozen
or not and so that's that's a field
called cryogenics so the reason that
people pay lots of money tens of
thousands of dollars to have their
relatives frozen after they pass away is
based on this hope that someday we're
going to be able to bring people back to
life we can freeze them solid and bring
them back to life and NASA wants to do
this to astronauts so you parents
thinking about whether you want your
kids to become astronauts take that into
mind as you encourage or discourage them
but there's a lot of interest in this
and people think about it like it's
science fiction that's crazy well it's
not crazy at all it's just we're not
sophisticated enough to do it but frogs
are so this is a great tree frog here
and this is a wood frog both of these
species live right around here and right
now today they're probably wishing that
they were frozen because it's just a
little too warm and it'd be much better
just to be kind of out of it rather than
sitting there getting rained on at this
temperature so this animal is absolutely
completely frozen solid its heart is not
beating if we brought this animal into a
hospital the doctor would say that's
that's a dead frog same thing for this
one but these frogs aren't dead at all
these frogs are in a torpor that allows
them so a kind of a sleepy state that
allows them to completely shut down
their heart their heart is not beating
their blood is absolutely frozen there's
no brain waves there's nothing going on
but what I'm going to show you in the
next slide is an example where somebody
took a wood frog that was completely
frozen and allowed it to thaw out so
we're going to be all modern here and
hop on the web so this is a some work
that was done at Miami University and
all they're doing is thawing out a wood
frog and what I'm going to show you as
it goes along is a ten hours that's
condensed into two minutes so what
you're going to see first is one of
these crusty looking frozen frogs and
one second of this video footage is
going to equal two minutes in real time
so
when they show the eye blink it's going
to happen a little bit fast so this is
at 20 28 minutes there's initial melting
of the skin so this is a completely
frozen frog okay and they're putting it
at higher temperature it's sitting on a
bed of sphagnum moss and there's not
much going on I doubt I could get you
guys to stay here for all 10 hours of
this if we weren't speeding it up but
after three hours and 12 minutes you're
going to just notice very little
twitches in the eye right here see that
okay pulmonary breathing returns
pulmonary just means the lung system and
so after almost four hours we're just
going to see if you look right here
you'll see the nose just twitching a
little bit ok so this animals starting
to take oxygen in for the first time
perhaps in months so if that's happening
it probably means that the heart has
started to beat a little bit and the
blood is being pushed around six hours
we get the first movement of the limbs
okay
yeah you have to imagine what this would
feel like to be frozen solid and then be
gradually thought out you know if you
sleep in a bad position you know how you
really sore when you're first waking up
you can see why this might take 10 hours
for this animal to come out of this and
sit now you're going to watch now things
are going to speed up so now this animal
after 10 hours and four minutes is ready
to roll and it's going to say see you
later I didn't like being filmed and you
can see the breathing really fast and
it's blinking and it's just going what
happened to me so why is that a good
idea these animals live in an
environment that you all live in but you
all live most likely in centrally heated
homes that regulate the temperature
sometimes you may complain that it's too
cold or whatever but what you're
complaining about is nothing like what a
wood frog has to deal with it's just
sitting underneath the leaf litter out
in the forest and that's going to get
down to below freezing and the only way
that it can deal with it is is by having
allowing itself to freeze wood frogs are
amazing animals this this is the most
widely distributed frog in the world it
lives down in Georgia it lives up at
Hudson Bay it lives same species is up
on the North Slope of Alaska beyond tree
line so the only way that it can have
such a broad distribution across most of
North America it's also out in Wyoming
and it's right around here is because it
has the ability to tolerate a huge range
of conditions and it can spend most of
the year like this and then 10 hours
blinking and it's off and it's ready to
do do whatever it needs to do breed feed
eat flies okay now what I want to do is
talk a little bit about just the
diversity of frogs that have evolved and
many of you who are familiar with frogs
at all will know the kind of life
history the kind of sequence of life
events that a wood frog goes through the
eggs are laid in the water the water
they develop into tadpoles not unlike
those gray tree frog tadpoles I showed
they spent a few months like that then a
metamorphose into these cute little
frogs that you see sometimes in the
summer those then grow up and they
Pete the process there are many other
ways to do this though in this animal
lives in South America this is known as
pipa pipa that's the species and the
genus name they're also called leaf
frogs and you can kind of see why
they're very flat really bizarre looking
animals they don't have any tongue most
frogs you know use their tongue to catch
things this animal lives underwater all
the time so it's got a big wide gaping
mouth and it's got these big hands and
it stuffs things into its face using
those hands but that's not the most
bizarre thing about it here's an example
for all you moms out there the moms lay
the eggs on the father's back ok and so
the male carries the entire clutch of
eggs and those of you have had twins can
look at this and think wow that's that's
quite a large number of babies and not
just that and I know some parents feel
like this the children actually grow
into the male's back ok and they
continue to develop and what this is
showing here is birth of this frog out
of the back of the father there's the
head there's one little arm already
looking to eat something before it's
even all the way out and it's just going
to swim off and say see you later which
kids do as well don't they so I wish I
could say that's the most bizarre but
it's it's not so this is an African
bullfrog this is one of the largest
frogs out there this animal is extremely
territorial these are both males and
while frogs don't generally have big
teeth they do have these big bony tusks
sometimes and these male bullfrogs
sometimes you can see this on Animal
Planet have these battles where they can
kill each other fighting over different
spots within a pond and these animals
can get quite large so this is this is a
little baby that's just turned from a
tadpole into what we call a metamorph
and there's a cricket so you can see
that it's very small and a few years
later it can be that big and that is a
normal scale kit that's not some trick
so these these animals get really large
and you can imagine this is a formidable
animal this mail again object lesson for
us
the male guards the tadpoles in the pond
it shepherds them around if the pond
starts to dry up it'll even dig a trench
into the deepest part of the pond so the
tadpoles can move and if anybody
including a biologist tries to mess
around with those tadpoles it will
attack using those tusks there are other
groups of frogs that you may have heard
about these are dark poison frogs that
live in Central and South America all of
these bizarre and wildly different
animals at least in color patterns are
all in the same family so they're all
very closely related and they've they've
developed into all these different
colors does anybody know why they might
have these very bright colors excellent
so they're warning other animals against
their lethal poison if you're going to
be a tiny little edible thing crawling
across the ground most most frogs have
that coloration like that barred River
frog I showed in the beginning where
they can blend into their background
these guys clearly are not blending in
at all and they are filled with toxins
that can kill things that try to eat
them and that's why the Central and
South American indigenous people used to
unfortunately take the points of their
arrows and grind them into the frogs and
cover the tips of their arrows with this
poison and then if they were hunting
they could shoot that into their their
prey that they were hunting and
immobilize it much more quickly does
anybody know how the poison gets in
there next row back from the arrow well
that it go the poison goes to the arrow
okay so it turns out that they get the
poison from the what they eat from the
ants that they eat and if you go to a
zoo or an exhibit where these are shown
they're not being fed the poisonous ants
and they're not poisonous now that is
not a recommendation to go try to eat
one of these I'm not saying that but
they're much less toxic when when
they're raised in captivity but that is
not I think the most interesting thing
about them the most interesting thing
once again a father story a happy
I'm a new father so I'm telling happy
father's stories so this is the blue
jeans frog this is one of and you can
see why it's called the blue jeans frog
it's got these blue blue pants on its
legs and this is one of the the dart
poison frogs and it the female lays the
eggs in bromeliads a bromeliad is a kind
of a plant that maybe you haven't heard
that word before but if you've ever seen
a pineapple you know what a bromeliad is
that's a type of a bromeliad and there's
a cup of water right in the middle here
and so the frog lays its eggs in there
and then the mail comes back after a few
weeks and sticks its its backside into
the water and the tadpole that's a
tadpole crawls up on its father's back
and then the father takes it to a new
bromeliad so it can eat the food in the
new one and they do this for months
until this this animal develops far
enough so that it can metamorphose and
become another adult blue jeans frog and
last but not least on this vein we have
what is kind of some people even think
an ugly frog this is the gastric
brooding frog that's a kind of a crazy
name this is another frog that lives in
Queensland in Australia where I've done
some of my work and this is kind of an
ordinary-looking frog but it's actually
a really probably perhaps the most
extraordinary of all frogs this is not
what it looks like this is not a parent
frog doing an awful thing to its its
baby this is oral birth so the the
female in this case eats the eggs ingest
them into her stomach and they developed
their inside the stomach and then
develop completely 22 metamorphosis in
there and then she burps them up okay
and and the one of the questions is how
does that happen you know if you tried
to eat one of your babies it would
digest right so these things somehow
have the ability to turn the stomach
acids off and and are able to complete
development and in the 1980s there was a
lot of interest for people with ulcers
of trying to figure out how that
happened
there must have been genes that could
turn this off and I've started to use
the past tense because the sad thing is
that this animal is extinct so this is
one of the species from all around the
world that in the last 20 years has gone
extinct and we really don't know why
we're starting to get some clues and I'd
be happy to answer questions about that
at the end okay so now I'm going to
segue into the second part of my talk so
this is me out in a pond looking
confused and so I'm being an example
here of a scientist and I'm a kind of a
scientist I'm a biologist and I'm going
to go out and try to figure out how
nature works so I've given you a whole
list of interesting things that people
have found out using frogs and so my job
is to try to add to that so to take the
what we know and then somehow build on
it so how does that happen and the
example I'm going to talk about is
something that some of you may have
heard of so starting about 10 years ago
there were reports all around North
America of frogs with very bad
developmental problems deformities and
this picture here from the cover of a
book that you could buy in airports and
stuff a plague of frogs the horrifying
true story shows one kind of deformity
where the Frog is has just a tiny little
leg and this is not a good way to be if
you want to grow up to be an older
healthy frog okay this animal if you put
it down on the ground hops around in
circles and says to every heron within a
hundred yards come eat me so while we
see deformed frogs and we find old frogs
we don't find old deformed frogs okay
this is an animal that we collected and
i'll tell you more about that in a
minute but you can see here it also has
a deformity and you can't see the other
leg but the other leg did too so this
animal is also in big trouble so one
question is does it matter beyond what's
happening to these poor frogs does it
matter for frogs and then maybe does it
matter to us because frogs like i said
before have backbones they have a lot of
the same genes we do if there's
something out in the environment that's
causing frogs to have developmental
problems
we probably should ask the question does
it matter for people because this frog
was collected in particular from part of
the public water drinking supply in
Vermont so if there was something in
that in that drinking supply that was
causing developmental problems in
another vertebrate we should know that
okay so some people think that the
reason I go to Vermont is so that I can
go to Ben and Jerry's and get free ice
cream and there is a limited amount of
truth to that so we when we selected the
places we were going to sample in
Vermont and I'll tell you more about
that in a moment one of the places and I
swear it popped up at random we didn't
do this on purpose was the pond next to
the corporate headquarters of ben and
jerry's and it turned out that the
people that work there on the weekend
were very nice to us and we got to try
all the newest experimental flavors when
we went up there so that was certainly
an added bonus but the real reason we
were up there is because Vermont has had
bad deformity problems so before I get
into talking about that I want to ask
all of you the question do you know what
causes these kinds of deformities if
you've heard about it yep poisons in the
water okay high amounts of ultraviolet
light pollution yeah in the back
somebody had their hand up okay over
here acid rain okay one more so the
cells don't copy themselves exactly so
maybe there's a developmental problem
for some reason okay all right those
that's that's a good that's a good job
so here's the list that that the
biologists that study these things have
been working on for the last ten years
so in answer the question what causes
amphibian deformities there have been
four main ideas that have been thrown
around one of them is that it's being
caused by predators so predators are
chopping off parts of the legs of frogs
and for a variety of reasons that can
cause a variety of deformities to happen
I'll talk about that one is one that was
mentioned ultraviolet light so maybe
there's too much ultraviolet light
out there because we're altering the
chemistry of the atmosphere and that's
leading to these problems another one
that nobody mentioned but is actually
the one that has gotten the most
attention is parasites infecting these
animals and causing developmental
problems and I'll talk quite a bit about
that and finally people said poisons or
pollution and and that's definitely one
of them that that people have thought
about some although probably the least
amount of work has been done on that so
far so the Vermont story started in 1996
so just just about 10 years ago now
people went out fishing and boating on
Lake Champlain and they started
reporting to the state government on
kind of an 800 hotline that there were
problems they were seeing frogs that had
the wrong number of legs and were
hopping around in circles and when the
state biologists went out and started to
look in some of these places along Lake
Champlain so here's the state of Vermont
and here's Lake Champlain running up the
western boundary of the state and that's
where these reports came from they
started finding places where one-third
of all the frogs had bad leg deformities
that's that's really high and it was
even enough to get Ted Koppel up there
and and go out figure out what's going
on and it was pretty much centered on
leopard frogs this species and it went
from all the way down here at poultney
Vermont all the way up to the Canadian
border so all along here they were
finding these problems so it was very
wide scale it caused people in Vermont
to get a very interested in this this is
a report that was produced about the
fate of frogs in Vermont and so there
was a lot of attention on this but not
no real answers so what we started doing
a few years ago was going up there to
try to figure out what's going on with
Vermont frogs we had those for ideas
that i showed you to begin with and our
job you know we're essentially being
paid we had a grant to do this our job
is to go up and figure out which of
these makes sense and which of them can
we eliminate so what we did was we went
up and studied a large number of ponds
one of the keys in science is sample
size you have to look at a bunch of
places not just one because if it's just
like studying if you want to stay out
you know whether smoking is related to
lung cancer
it you can look at one person but you
get much better Lancers if you look at a
whole bunch of people so the same thing
is true here we're going to have to go
to a bunch of places we restricted
ourselves to the part of the state where
this had initially been reported but we
actually extended the the area that we
were going to look at we weren't just
going to look right along the shoreline
of Lake Champlain we were going to look
at the Champlain basin which is actually
maybe fifty percent of the state or more
and so that goes all the way down to the
shore line from the top of the mountains
in the Green Mountain National Forest
and we're going to look at the
characteristics of these ponds in part
to see whether ponds that have lots of
deformities or somehow different from
ones that don't and we visited each
place lots of times this is three or
more but really we ended up going to
each one of these places many many times
and each time we went we collected up to
100 individuals of each species we
encountered of both amphibians and
snails now I haven't talked about snails
yet but I will more and that will make
sense for why we're doing that and that
allowed us to look at parasites among
other things okay so we have to we have
to collect these animals and we have to
kill them in order to to figure this
stuff out and that's another part of
biology if any of you have been in a
class we've dissected a frog that frog
was sacrificed so that you can learn
about this so we have to be really
careful about figuring out what we're
doing so that we know how many
individuals were going to need and we
collect no more than that because we
don't want to become part of the problem
for these frog populations we're trying
to figure out ways of helping out and so
this involves lots of fieldwork so this
is Susan Bolden she's the research
technician in my lab and so she and I
and others who will list at the end went
out and did a lot of this work and
that's another part of biology is that
this kind of field biology is a
tremendous amount of work it's lots of
fun because you get to be outside but
you get to be outside on nice days which
is nice like when I was eating the ice
cream on the grass and when this picture
was taken but you're outside on days
like this too and you can't just say
gosh I'd rather be in watching TV or
something you got to do it anyway if
you're on a schedule that says you're
going to be here on that day you're
there even if it's grueling and ugly out
okay so I'm going to step through each
one of these four ideas and talk about
each one of them and why it may or may
not make sense so predators first of all
why do predators potentially make sense
as a cause well it turns out that
something horrible called limb grazing
is common so this is this is kind of a
tough idea you've got all these baby
frogs out in their playground hopping
around or not popping around swimming
around and while they're still swimming
around they've got a tail that they're
using to swim but they also have their
legs developing and if a predator comes
along maybe it's a fish maybe it's
another frog maybe it's some kind of
insect one of the easiest handles that
they can grab on to if they're trying to
grab and eat that tadpole is the
developing lid limb once it gets big
enough that leg that's sticking out and
sometimes when that happens they
actually eat the limb and they don't get
the rest of the animal so that leaves
this kind of evidence I'm sure all of
you at home have your field guide to
malformations of frogs and toads so that
that turns out that's a real book and
under 11 see you can see trauma limb
amputation the terminal margin of the
right femur is blunt that means the leg
is blunt and it's irregular yep that
looks irregular red and swollen
indicating trauma so this animal somehow
met with something that that chopped its
leg off and hemorrhage can be seen so
that that blood right there so it turns
out that predator attacks as you could
imagine having your leg chopped off
leads to bleeding it leads to scarring
it leads to changes in the pigment the
coloring sometimes there's exposed bone
and sometimes and this we don't see in
people although some people wish we
could do this frogs can regenerate so
some of you may know this this animal
may be able to regrow its leg okay if it
happens at the in the right way and this
heals cleanly frogs and salamanders can
start to regrow that leg so that by the
time several months have gone by that
animal could look close to normal but
even when that happens you can still
tell something happen because there's
the scarring and there's
changes in the pigmentation so in short
what we did is not to say this doesn't
happen but we eliminated it from our
sample so of all the animals we
collected if we saw any evidence that
put us on to 11c we cut it out we just
said we're not going to count those okay
it turns out that we saw some of that
but not that much it's it's happening
but I wouldn't say it's a very high rate
but we were just being very conservative
we were being very careful to make sure
that that's not what we're studying
because people don't think that this is
probably a big problem it's not
something that's changed a lot in the
last few years that would lead to all
these people all of a sudden seeing
these deformed frogs so we're going to
eliminate that one from consideration
using the methods that we're going to
going to adopt the next thing is one
that somebody mentioned and that's
ultraviolet light so ultraviolet light
had been linked earlier with amphibian
declines so some populations
particularly in the western US were
declining and it was linked to
ultraviolet light causing a disease in
the eggs so when people started seeing
these limb deformities they started
asking well maybe ultraviolet light is
related to that as well and so some
people at an EPA lab out in Minnesota
did some very good experiments that
showed that first of all I'll
ultraviolet light in too large of a dose
too much can cause leg deformities so it
absolutely can cause leg deformities in
the laboratory one of the things they
found though is that it only causes one
class of problems missing legs or parts
of legs and it happens in a very
particular way it's always both legs and
it's always identical so this animal
here is missing both of its legs at the
same point so that's consistent with
this idea ultraviolet light might have
caused that but this is what most of our
animals look like in the sense that it's
only on one side almost all of our
animals over ninety-nine percent the two
legs look different okay so what we can
do just on that basis is throw this idea
out
and and we're not doing anything that
the EPA people didn't do themselves so
they were good responsible scientists
they showed that yes it can cause leg
deformities but they figured this
pattern out and they looked themselves
at what what people were seeing all
around the country and they decided that
this red X should go here themselves so
they threw it out and that's really
important some of the most important
scientific discoveries that are made are
ones that allow us to say it's not that
because remember we started out with
four ideas we've got to get down to one
if we want to be able to say something
or at least know that there's more than
one of those as they're operating and
maybe they're interacting with each
other or not but we want to get down to
the list of things that really matter
and discard the ones that don't just
like doctors do when they're trying to
figure out how to treat disease we have
to know what really matters and and when
I went out from what doesn't so next I'm
going to talk about parasites and I'm
going to talk about a particular kind of
a parasite that's been associated with
these leg deformities so trematodes are
probably not something that many of you
who have heard of it's a kind of a
parasite this is a picture of of one
life history stage and like a lot of
parasites it has a bizarre life history
so what happens to it during its life
Hollywood couldn't even made up yeah so
what is a parasite a parasite is an
animal that lives inside of other
animals and it makes a living off of
being on the inside of somebody else and
I hate to break the news to you but all
of you have parasites it's been said
that if we all of a sudden made
everything on earth disappear except for
nematodes which is just one kind of
parasites you'd be able to see for that
split second the outline of every living
creature because there are so many of
these things in all of us so there's
something to think about for the rest of
the talk and now you won't pay attention
to anything else I say so there are lots
of parasites out there and in fact this
is the dominant form of life if you're
either counting species how many species
are out there or how many individuals
because every host so this is a host
this is a host this is a host has
any parasites in it and every species of
host and you're a host and I'm a host
has many different species living within
it so this is life on Earth most life on
Earth is parasites and it but it's this
kind of hidden thing and all of us want
to thank you know most people in this
room if you ask are you healthy or not
you'd say yes I'm healthy but we're also
infected so being infected is not
inconsistent with our own ideas about
our health but if we said if I had
before if I had giving you this little
spiel and I said you know I know you
have parasites does that mean you're
healthy you might have said well gosh no
that's that's not normal but in fact it
is normal to be to be infected but
sometimes these infections can be of the
wrong kind or they can be super intense
and they can cause health problems so
trematodes are in that class if any of
you have ever heard of swimmers itch or
had it that's when one of these things a
trematode is trying to infect a duck and
I'm not saying anything about your legs
but it's thinks that you're a duck and
it swims into your leg instead of a
duck's leg and it causes it doesn't it
doesn't manage to infect your legs but
while it's in there trying and dying it
causes a rash and that's what swimmers
itch is okay so you're swimming that's
where you get it and you which and you
do and there's other diseases they're
actually really serious schistosomiasis
is a very bad disease that infects
people all over the tropical world and
there are almost as many people infected
with that as there are eight it's a big
big problem and it can be lethal for
kids and older people so there are
certain kinds of diseases caused by
these things that can be really bad but
there are many other animals and plants
that are infected with trematodes that
don't even notice it ok so the life
history of this thing goes like this
this is a heron and the Heron is
actually right here it's got a frog in
its mouth so herons eat frogs and if
this frog is infected it's going to be
seated standing in the water and and
when it poops that that is going to have
the parasite eggs in it those eggs are
going to hatch out and they're going to
swim around and find a snail and when
they go
into this snail they form these breeding
complexes there's not a better word for
it and they do if any of you guys have
seen alien the movie some of you were
probably too young and you shouldn't see
alien ever but what happens is that they
grow up inside this snail and take over
the whole body and then when it warms up
in the springtime this thing is going to
explode and thousands of these things
are going to pour out and that's the end
of the snail and then these are going to
swim and infect a tadpole and so it's
this process of infecting the tadpole
that many people think has been linked
to these developmental problems because
this parasite doesn't just infect
anywhere on the tadpole it infects right
there that's where the hind limb is
going to be now if you think about it
this is not a bad strategy for this
parasite it wants to get eaten by a
heron right if it doesn't get eaten by a
heron its life is over okay it can't
move on to the next stage it can't
infect the next stage by laying eggs so
what better way to do it then to mess up
the legs of the frog that you're living
in so it can't get away from the heron
and so people think that this might
actually be an evolutionary strategy to
help these things get eaten by this and
complete this thing's life cycle evil
okay so let's think about why would this
be linked with with limb deformities how
does this work and what I'm showing you
here are animals that were
experimentally infected with these
reiber o'yea so that's the species that
can cause these deformities so this
animal was experimentally infected this
animal was experimentally infected this
animal was experimentally infected a
couple of these look kind of bizarre
this looks almost like an x-ray and this
animal it's not an x-ray it's called
clearing and staining so if we want to
look inside of an animal we can actually
put it in a series of solutions that
turns all the flesh clear and then dies
the bones and the cartilage different
colors and that allows us to see if
there are any parasites in there in this
x-ray right here what you can see is an
arrow that's pointing to a bunch of tiny
little dots those tiny little dots are
trematodes cysts so after that trematode
swims in and burrows into the limb bud
it puts a little shell around itself and
it just sits there and waits for the
Frog to get eaten in this case the Frog
didn't get eaten it got caught and
photographed and and we can see there
that there's a concentration of those
cysts there and so what scientists were
able to do using a bunch of really
clever experiments is show that just the
just the presence of those cysts not
anything that they're excreting or
secreting or anything like that pushes
the cells apart and when your limbs were
developing when you were just an embryo
you had a little paddle shaped hand or
do not even a hand just a little limb
bud and the way that you got a thumb and
first finger second finger and so on is
because a field set up of concentrations
of hormones in your in your little limb
bud and this part of your limb bud said
I am a thumb and don't you dare over
there become a thumb and sent the signal
across the developing hand and this one
said okay I'll be a first finger then
and okay I'll be the second and so on
and that's the way you get a
differentiated hand well if if someone
had been nasty enough to put a bunch of
trematode cysts in between the cells
that we're going to turn into the thumb
and the rest of the hand that cuts that
chemical communication off and you can
get multiple legs developing you see
this thing's got two feet and two bones
here it's a big mess and so they were
able to show that because what they did
was they they took little plastic beads
that were exactly the same size as these
trematode cysts and they surgically put
them into a limb bud of a frog they
repeated this many times and they got
the exact same thing so it's just the
physical presence of those little
parasites in the developing limb that
can do this so now the question is is
reiber o'yea the answer in vermont and
the answer so far is we don't know this
this sounds like it could be something
that we should investigate and so what
we did is we went up to Vermont
and we looked at the pattern of
deformities up there and one of the
things that we found is that there was a
real bias almost all the deformities we
saw were one kind so before I said that
there are two main classes of
deformities so there's where you're
missing something so this animal should
have another leg right here this is a
metamorph so this thing still has its
tail but it's got a leg here it's got
its forelegs here there should be
another hind leg here but it's just not
there it's gone so that goes in the
missing column this animal obviously has
some extra legs so we put it over here
extra now you know if you think about
this and you were a TV news producer and
somebody gave you two pictures which one
would you put on the news this one and
so almost all the newspaper magazine and
television coverage has shown this
business but as I'll show you this is
the business this is what's going on out
in nature so that's what we found up in
Vermont why is that important that's
important because people have done these
experiments I talked about when they've
infected animals with this parasite
reiber oh yeah so these are all
experiments so none of these animals
would have been infected except an
experimenter took half of them and said
okay you're in the control group and the
other half and they gave them some of
these parasites and allowed them to
infect the limb buds and then we asked
how many of the deformities involved
missing stuff or extra stuff so if this
number was 0 for this species this is
Bufo Boreas the Western toad if that
number was 0 it would mean all of the
deformities involved missing elements
like what we saw in Vermont if it's a
hundred percent and it nearly is that
means all of the deformities seen
involved extra limbs like the television
frog I showed this is specific tree frog
it's bias the same way and the leopard
frog bias the same way so these are the
only experiments anyone has done where
they've experimentally infected these
animals and then look to see what
happens and we get this pattern now
remember what we saw in Vermont is the
opposite
very few extra limb deformities out in
nature so that's inconsistent with what
people are seeing when they do these
very careful experiments so we got a
problem so what we did is we asked the
question if rye bro it was present in
Vermont what would the deformities look
like ok so if this was the answer what
should we see and we did an experiment
up at the Yale forest where we took
Vermont leopard frogs and New York
reiber OE and I'll explain why we had to
do that in a minute and we reared them
up to metamorphosis and this is what we
found this is an extra limb deformity so
even though we're not seeing these very
much at all out in nature that's all we
got out of these tanks when we did the
experimental infection okay another
problem we've got an inconsistency the
big news though is that reiber o'yea is
not present in Vermont we have looked
and looked and looked until we were
ready to scream and we can't find it so
we've looked in 50 different ponds we
know that that hosts nail that it's
coming from the right species is there
there's only a few species that can use
and they're there and they're abundant
so we've looked in the snails we've
looked in the frogs and I have to add
that we know what we're doing because
when when we when we presented these
results to people who believe that
trematodes are causing this stuff even
though we're all scientists and we're
all adults they say well you just don't
know how to do this you don't know how
to find them but what this is showing is
that we can go over to new york state
where we got those raipur olia for that
experiment I just showed you and in 10
minutes we can find rye Broly over there
so they're present in upstate New York
that's where some of the researchers who
have looked at this or from and this is
showing a little bloody spot next to the
limb bud of this tadpole where we just
had released some rye berroa and they go
right into the limb bud and then we
followed this guy and we get a picture
like that one that I just showed you of
the extra limbs but it's not there it's
not out there in Vermont
and we did some digging around in the
literature so when scientists talk about
literature they don't mean Charles
Dickens or dr. Seuss they mean all these
really boring papers that almost never
none of you have ever read and maybe if
you're lucky you never will have to so
these are all published papers where
people put their results out there and
then people can read it I'm just kidding
you should all learn how to read that
otherwise you have to trust these
newspaper and television editors so
anyway this is that this is just like
that figure I showed before where this
is fifty percent of extra Lin I'm
malformations if it's above that it
means we've got television frogs if it's
below that we don't we've got mostly
deformities of these missing limbs and
this is a whole list of species and what
you can see is that there are only five
bars that cross this line where most of
the limb problems are extra okay and all
of them except one are this H rajala
that's the Pacific tree frog and there's
one exception here and I won't get into
it but but the this has an asterisk next
to it because these people only looked
in ponds where they knew reiber oh it
was present so they're kind of stacking
the deck in doing that but basically
what it means with or without that
caveat almost everything that's going on
out in nature looks like for what we saw
in Vermont okay so the story is a
missing limb story we did another thing
just to make sure just to double-check
we weren't off track so maybe there's
some other trematode out there that we
don't know about that can cause these
deformities and what we did is we looked
at a bunch of deformed animals that
we're going to call cases and a bunch of
controls and the controls in the cases
were the same species they were
collected on the same day from the same
pond and we asked of those two animals
and we're matching them up with each
other which one had more trematodes
underneath its skin and to do this we
have to dissect all the skin off the
animal and count every little trematode
cyst and they're just fractions of a
millimeter wide and my people in my lab
hate me when I make them do this and if
if the answer was they have exactly the
same number every point would
exactly on that line if we got the
answer that was suggesting that the
trematodes were causing these problems
then the point should be down in this
area the ones that have the deformities
should have more assists than the ones
that don't and the answer was things are
lined up pretty well on that line so
nothing going on there that suggests
that other trematodes not really because
it's not present other trematodes have
anything to do with with what's
happening so there's a very strong case
against the trematode idea for vermont
most importantly Ribery is not there and
without Ribery at present there's a big
problem with the hypothesis nearly all
the deformities are also missing legs
they're not extra legs and what that
means is that we don't have a pattern
that's consistent with what we see from
Ribery anyway and our experiment is
consistent with that and we're
double-checking and we don't find any
evidence that other trematodes that are
out there are associated with this
problem ok so let's go back to this list
there's one that I held out on you and
one that you mentioned when I asked you
what's causing these patterns and that's
pollution so we didn't go up there
specifically to study pollution people
who study pollution environmental
chemists and others have to use very
expensive very specific techniques and
we just didn't have the money for that
in our grant but we were keeping our
eyes open about this and so what we did
instead since we didn't measure
pollution directly what we did is we
asked a question we asked if pollution
was causing these problems what would
the pattern look like in Vermont and one
of the things we were particularly
interested in is whether if a pond was
near agricultural fields where
pesticides are being sprayed or people's
lawns where sometimes chemicals are
sprayed or where septic fields are and
so forth whether those ponds were
particularly likely to have deformed
amphibians and what we found was as many
of you know Vermont has a lot of
Agriculture and in particular dairy cows
right well those dairy cows have to be
fed something and usually it's it's corn
that the dairy farmer grows right on the
on the farm right there and they spray
pesticides and all
things on there and what we found is
that frogs that grow up near these
agricultural fields have more than twice
the likelihood of developing a leg
deformity now that is not the same as
saying we know it's pollution there are
other reasons that this could be going
on and this is often the way science
works I've been working on this problem
for several years and what I've been
able to do is knock some of those things
out now that list was not created by me
other people created that list and what
I'm left with on that list is that one
line their pollution and so instead of
saying concluding by telling you
pollutions the answer I have to conclude
by saying pollution is the next thing
that we have to look at that's where
we're at so it looks like the patterns
are consistent with that but we don't
even know what pollutant could cause
this there's many many unanswered
questions and that's the good thing
about you know this whole employment
messing around with frogs thing you can
always come up with a new problem that
you can try to sell to somebody to keep
you going so I want to finish up but
just by reconsidering the Frog so frogs
have taught us lots about nature we've
been able to use them to answer all
kinds of questions and the good news is
that we have accumulated a huge amount
of information about this one kind of
animal and now we can use on that we can
build on it to ask other questions and
maybe we can get to the point where we
can understand what's causing these
kinds of problems so that maybe we can
figure out how to make that not happen
anymore now just as Aneesa said when she
was saying there are a bunch of behind
the scenes people out there the other
part about science is that science is
done by teams of people large teams of
people and many of the people up here
are the ones who are actually out there
doing a lot of this work there's there's
people have have to have very
specialized skills in different arenas
so some people are good at going outside
and finding these things some people are
really good at identifying parasites
some people are really good at
dissecting animals and some of those
people are all right here and the other
part of this is that science is not
cheap it takes money to hire these
people to do these things to buy the
equipment to do
the stuff and so we've had lots of
people to help out and finally I wanted
to finish by thanking all of you for
listening